yo this chapter is insane I gotta say
that right off the bat with Luffy's
insane shocking fight with kizaru with
the Zoros also hype fight with Luchi
awaken Lucci mind you and Elder Saturn
coming into play and more so make sure
to stay tuned for this iconic epic
chapter shallow parakeet with it and
smash that like button if you enjoy
these chapter reviews I want to keep
them coming make this the video you
joined the knock if you haven't already
by hitting that subscribe button you can
help us reach our insane goal of 2
million subscribers on YouTube if you
like one piece that I'm sure you can
relate to insane ambitious goals like
that too so thank you so much if you did
help and now without further Ado let's
jump into It spoilers and all last
chapter we left off with gear 5 giant
form Luffy becoming the Goliath rather
than the David for once and grabbing the
tiny by comparison Admiral Kizer with
his hand that chapter kizaru was saying
stuff like you certainly are the man who
defeated kaido and the best part is that
was before Luffy even went and gear 5
high praise to be sure and when kizaru
finally sees Luffy he says it finally
appeared so this is the rumor hyping up
this fight even more between gear 5
Luffy and kizaru I was saying that yeah
if he used gear 5 versus Luchi then
Luffy definitely should have started
with that against kizuru but hey he is
using it now and this current chapter is
called Luffy vs kizaru so Oda is finally
delivering by focusing on full power
Luffy versus full power kizuru so the
chapter starts with kizaru getting spun
around by Luffy kizuru's expression is
unchanged and he is very calm I
mentioned this in the last chapter that
it was notable how everyone's eyes
popped out like in Bugs Bunny except
kizarus and here again Otis focusing on
kizuru's calm and unchanging face again
this may be teasing the fact that kizuru
can use his own Mastery of hockey to
counteract the effect of Luffy's toon
force to an extent so that we cut to the
control room and then Punk decides to go
to fabirio phase with Sanji and Atlas
definitely glad to see someone like
Sanji with vegapunk a good move to be
sure the group wants to say Bonnie and
of course Sanji wants to do that but
also to change the pacifista's orders
with the authority chip and I love this
part we're told Vega Punk will use his
own vehicle the Vega tank and that
sounds like Mega Punk's own Batmobile
very cool now this export is very
interesting vegapunk refers to Bonnie as
a little child he talks about her as if
she's a really small kid combine this
with Kizer who's saying last chapter
you've grown so much to Bonnie and that
kiss these days sure grow fast it's
beginning to seem like Bonnie's real age
may be younger than we've been thinking
let me know what age you think Bonnie is
below in the comments and you get
bragging rights if you get it right just
no editing your comments later so if
it's an edited comment it doesn't count
for the record she was estimated to be
22 before the time Skip and 24 after
through the time skip her Bounty of 320
million may turn out to be very
impressive indeed for her age depending
on what it is so now we jump to Nami
usab and Edison who remain in the
control room jinbei is carrying all
vegapunk's stuff to the back of the
island Lilith is using Frankie's Shogun
to carry the Thousand Sunny to the same
point that jimbe is going to Frankie for
his part is going down to the fiberio
phase as well we then jump to said
fabirio phase and Bonnie is fighting
against the Marines I always love to see
her in action and how she uses her devil
fruit to fight centomaru saved her when
Bonnie was falling down after she hit
Egghead barrier then satomaru passes out
but he's alive and isn't it interesting
that kizuru didn't kill this guy he's
got history with Buddha keeps
emphasizing how he's constantly trying
to avoid hurting people he knows and now
he left santomaru okay enough to help
the enemy mark my words some kisuru
twists May well be coming very soon we
then cut to something I'm so glad Oda
did Zoro versus Luchi part of me was
very underwhelmed after kind doing King
that Luffy was fighting Luchi and that
Zorro was fighting Kaku awakened giraffe
or not but this matchup I can get behind
interestingly zoro's swords have flames
on them we're told and Luchi paying
respect to our Zorro is using his
awakened form thankfully Kaku does not
appear in this chapter which makes sense
hopefully he's still in his bubble and
stays there throughout this conflict I
don't even want to see Sanji taking him
on if we're being honest Zoro says some
hype stuff here stuff I've been thinking
and hoping to see he says to awaken
Luchi with this level you won't get the
fight or Captain and Luchi doesn't put
Zorro down at all in fact he says it is
worth killing the number two of ayanko's
crew end quote so I'm glad to see Luchi
is showing respect to Zorro and I can't
wait to see Zorro crush him because you
know that's gonna happen some misled
people in the comment section were
remarking that Luffy gear 5 didn't do so
well against Luchi and then ran out of
steam and turned back into his melting
looking form but in reality he was
outclassing Luchi and then when he no
longer needed the fight he released a
transformation we already know from
kaido that if he really needs to he
can't even use the form twice at the
very least twice he just didn't need to
there so that's why he didn't do it or
stay in the form and I'm glad Oda is
making this clear by having Zorro match
up with Luchi this time and even
remarking that he's not impressed with
his level beautiful stuff so then we
turn to the main event Luffy versus
Admiral kizuru Luffy throws kisado
towards the sea actually a really smart
idea especially for Luffy since even
someone like his or would be paralyzed
in the sea however you know it's not
going to be that easy kisuru flies back
and I love what he does here but you
gotta wait for a while to see why I love
it exactly so in the beginning he
creates multiple like clones of himself
it seems it's an extension of his
yasakani no magatama technique AKA
yasakani string of jewels kizuru's
clones give Luffy minor injuries with
their light swords but we all know minor
injuries are like no injuries in one
piece fights especially when you're
dealing with an awakened mythical Zone
like come on Luffy then uses gomugomuno
Dawn stamp to destroy all kisaru clones
but the real kizaru is not there and
that's what I loved honestly I've seen
clone attacks so much and Shonen I
wasn't excited to see it again but the
fact that he dipped and used them as a
distraction I did love that twist the
real kisado being the man on a mission
that he is and like that he always seems
to be has left Luffy and returned to the
control room to kill vegapunk but as you
remember Vega Punk's already gone kizuru
then flies towards the powerfully named
vega tank and attacks it with surprise
surprise light but Luffy follows and
defends the Vega tank very nice Luffy
takes in kizaru's light we're told and
it splits in multiple directions pretty
possible that he could just tank the
attack like that that was meant to
destroy a Vega tank thanks to Luffy the
Vega tank arrives safely to the fiberio
phase as planned near the end of the
chapter Atlas is overwriting kisuru's
order to the pacifistas things are
looking very good maybe too good and
we're about to get into that but you
can't deny that these straw hats are
looking pretty Victorious for the most
part right now everything seems to be
going their way kizero had to create
clones to escape from Luffy because he
couldn't just take him out quickly in
other words he was running from our
protagonist but if you'll remember there
is another big wild card that the
Marines have yet to play and the final
panel focuses on just that in the last
panel the scene changes and we see Elder
Saturn staring menacingly we're told
there's a breaknext chapter but what a
chapter to leave us with before the
break thankfully Saturn is finally
coming into play and that's not
surprising considering how everything
here seems to be going to straw Hat's
way at least for now but let me know
your thoughts what do you think Saturn
the wild card will be able to accomplish
as the first Elder that we see in action
will the world government be able to do
anything meaningful again sufi's
awakened mythical Zone and if you think
Luffy's powers are interesting then you
won't want to miss my all seven yako and
their powers explained where I talk
about Luffy and of course the other
yonko and their powers like on-screen
right now don't forget to like And
subscribe to help us reach the one piece
level ambitious goal of 2 million
subscribers on YouTube thank you so much
and I'll see you in the next one